finland and sweden will be warmly
welcomed into the nato military alliance
that was the message from all nato
foreign ministers at a meeting in berlin
except for one
turkey has made objections saying the
nordic nations are hosting what it calls
terrorist organizations pointing among
others at the pkk the kurdish workers
party to be frank i'm a bit confused
because i had a telephone discussion
with the president earlier on that is
approximately a month ago
and
actually he took up himself before i had
a possibility to do that that you're
applying for nato membership
and we will assess it favorable
i thanked him
and he was very pleased
receiving my thanks
for turkey there was nothing confusing
about its demands
they need to stop supporting terrorist
organizations the defense industry
restriction over prohibitions on export
permits imposed to an allies such as
turkey should definitely be lifted i'm
not saying this is a bargaining chip i'm
saying it as a requirement of alliance
russia's president vladimir putin has
called the possible northern expansion
of nato a threat
finland joining would double the border
between nato and russia but nato's
minister said putin has himself to blame
after invading ukraine they're confident
the issue with turkey will be resolved
soon i heard
almost across the board very strong
support for finland nato joining the
alliance if that's what they choose to
do
and i'm very confident that we will
reach consensus on that
all 30 nato states have to approve the
admission of new members a process that
normally takes months but ministers in
berlin said they want to speed this up
to prevent the so-called grey period in
which finland and sweden would not be
protected by nato's article 5 which says
an attack on one is an attack on all
it was expected that as soon as finland
and sweden applied for nato membership
the process would be smooth and swift
but turkey's position may now have
slowed this down no one can say for sure
when the tumor flex will be added to
this collection step faster al jazeera
in berlin